- All right.
- If we, if we tied,
Christina cheated.
- No (laughing) shut up.
- That's clearly, what happened
(laughing). - Hey, I'm
Christina Milian.
- And I'm Sinqua Walls.
- And we star in the new
Netflix film "Resort to Love."
And now it is time to
play the rom-com quiz.
Round one: Finish the line.
- "I'm just a girl
standing in front
of a boy asking him to..."
- Ooh, "feed me"!
(buzzer chiming)
(panelists laughing)
Feed me. That's the way
to my heart.
- One of my favorite
moments from "Notting Hill."
"To love her"!
(bell chiming)
"You had me at--"
- "Hello"!
(bell chiming)
- Yes!
- Who doesn't know this one?
"Jerry Maguire."
- "Nobody, nobody--"
- Ooh!
(Christina snapping fingers)
- "Puts Baby--
- "In the corner"!
Yes.
(bell chiming)
- Yes, "Dirty Dancing."
Now you're speaking my language.
"When you realize
you wanna spend
"the rest of your life
with someone,
you want the rest
of your life to..."
- To be with him.
(buzzer chiming)
- Uh--
- To spend the rest
of your life with them.
(buzzer chiming)
Is it, is it "My Best
Friend's Wedding," right?
(buzzer chiming)
- Dangit!
- It's not
"My Best Friend's Wedding?"
"When you realize
you wanna spend
"the rest of your life
with someone,
you want the rest of your life
to start as soon as possible."
I am taking that.
- Aw, that is a great caption.
IG, hello.
- Caption?
It's gonna be a pickup line.
(Christina laughing)
"You should be with someone."
Who?
- Ooh, I heard this before.
Caleb, in "Resort to Love?"
(belling chiming)
- Yo, did he say?
He did say that.
- He did say that!
- It was Caleb.
- It's you!
"You should be with someone--"
- "Who is sure that you
are the only one for them."
- Yes!
- That was teamwork right there.
(romantic music)
Round two: Rom-com
or horror movie?
- Ooh, sounds like my life.
(panel laughing)
Just kidding.
"A disgruntled man scams his way
"into staying near
his cheating ex,
"keeping tabs on her
and her boyfriend
while on a getaway--"
- Rom-com for 500.
(bell chiming)
- Yes.
"Forgetting Sarah Marshall."
- Yeah!
"A woman falls hard
for her dream man,
"but soon finds out
he's been hiding
"shocking secrets
from his past.
"But she must go to the
other side of the world
to uncover them."
- I'ma go with horror movie.
- I'm gonna say horror movie.
(buzzer chiming)
Dang it!
(Sinqua grunting)
- "Crazy Rich Asians."
- Oh, ding dong.
"A man and his wife decide
"to become summer
caretakers of an old hotel.
But they have
unexpected company."
- It's rom-com.
(buzzer chiming)
- Definitely sounds
like horror.
(bell chiming)
Yay!
"Here's Johnny!"
(panel laughing)
I'm hiding (laughing).
Thanks so much
for playing with us.
- And make sure you guys
watch "Resort to Love,"
only on Netflix.
(abstract music)